Near the end of the last video,
I wasn't as articulate
as I would like to be.
Mainly because I think 15
minutes into a video my brain
starts to really warm
up too much.
But what I want to do
is restate what I
was trying to say.
We got this confidence
interval.
I'll rewrite it here.
I'll just restate the
confidence interval.
So there's the 95% confidence
interval for the mean of this
distribution.
So, the mean of that
distribution, we got as being
1.91 plus or minus 1.21.
And near the end of the
video I tried to
explain why that is neat.
Because here we have this
confidence interval for this
weird mean of the difference
between the sampling means.
So it seems kind of confusing.
But I just want to
restate what we
saw in previous videos.
This thing right over here, the
mean of the difference of
the sampling means, we saw
two or three videos ago.
It's the same thing as the mean
of the difference of the
means of the sampling
distributions.
And we know that the mean
of each of the sampling
distributions is actually the
same as the mean of the
population distributions.
So this is the same thing as
the mean of Population One
minus the mean of
Population Two.
And this was the neat result
about the last video.
This isn't just a 95% confidence
interval for this
parameter right here.
It's actually a 95% confidence
interval for this parameter
right here.
And this is the parameter that
we really care about.
The true difference in weight
loss between going on the
low-fat diet and not going
on the low-fat diet.
And we have a 95% confidence
interval that that difference
is between 0.7 and
3.12 pounds.
Which tells us that we have a
95% confidence interval that
you're definitely going
to lose some weight.
We're not 100% sure.
We're confident that there's
a 95% probability of that.
Anyway, hopefully that clarifies
it a little bit.
I didn't want to confuse you
too much with that bungled
language that I had at the
end of the last video.